JAKE: I had this
experience at work once
where I was leaving work.
I had my headphones in, I
was listening to some stuff.
And I went to the bathroom.
I went to the urinals,
because I needed to do a wee.
And--
PAUL: Thanks for that update.
JAKE: And as it was
happening, I moved my hand,
and I knocked my earphones.
PAUL: No, no, no.
JAKE: Yeah.
You know what's coming, right?
And it was just like this
slow motion of them falling.
And there was peoples at
the urinals next to me,
so I couldn't do
anything about it, right?
PAUL: You didn't knock it into--
JAKE: Well, no, no.
Well, if "Ghostbusters"
taught me anything,
don't cross the streams,
right, is the key rule.
No, I couldn't catch it.
But once they landed in
there, they're ruined, right?
PAUL: Yes.
You're not going to shove
those back in your--
JAKE: So I just carried on.
And it was just this
really depressing moment
where I just continued to
urinate on my earphones.
PAUL: How is this
in any way related?
JAKE: Because that reminds
me of so many websites.
I've been being
reminded of that moment
when developing
so many websites.
And it's because
if something like
that-- when you're
developing for i6, it's like,
why even try at that point?
It's already been pissed on.
They're already ruined,
so why not just carry on?
Just to carry on.
PAUL: Just make it.
JAKE: I still think the web
has the simplest Hello World,
right?
It's just doc type, Hello World,
and now you have a web page.
It's all you need.
PAUL: Or is it?
No.
JAKE: Yes it is.
PAUL: No it's not.
No, because we've made
it impossible, frankly.
JAKE: We haven't
made it impossible.
PAUL: Yes we have.
To get going with the
web, first install NPM.
Then probably install Bower.
And then you install
Gulp or Grunt or both.
And then download all
the modules you need.
And then you wrap bizarre
things like [? Watcherify ?]
around Browserify
around BaileyFY.
And then stand on one
leg, face due east
and then, and only then,
are you good enough
to build for the web.
JAKE: What you're
talking about there
isn't building
something for the web,
it's being excellence
to the web.
It's making the web really good.
And I know that's different.
OK, go on.
PAUL: Because no.
Because every single
tutorial, when
you get past their little
world, it's going to say,
in order to proceed, you're
going to require these tools.
You're making it
sound like there's
a kind of on ramp,
where we gently go,
I know you've got
this far with the web,
but now you need to just
ease across to these tools.
Oh, and they're lovely
and easy to work with.
No, no, no.
We just go, to begin, first
to invent the universe.
I do get it.
And that like, I don't want
to say that the tools are bad,
the tools the wrong.
But I am concerned that the
next generation of developers
is going to get
somehow left behind.
It feels like we're not taking
enough care over that journey
that people are going to
naturally have to go through.
I saw this with Flash, actually.
When ActionScript
got so advanced,
and the tooling got so advanced,
that it was just a brick wall.
And one of the great
strengths of Flash
is that it had all these
designers coming in early on.
People who were naturally,
sort of inclined to code.
But they started to dabble,
and then the dabbling
became good and professional.
And then before
you know it, you've
got these people who would
have never described themselves
as coders, doing
these amazing things.
And they bring diversity.
They bring interesting things.
JAKE: This is not a new
problem with the web, though.
You go onto Stack
Overflow, and you
find the question of how do
I hide an element on the web.
And the answer is wow,
it's just a single line.
And that single line uses--
PAUL: jQuery.
JAKE: jQuery!
Absolutely, it does.
And so we're just
kind of switching out
jQuery as a prerequisite
for something on NPM now.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL: No we're not.
No, because with jQuery,
at least I can go there,
and I can hit a big
download button.
And I can get jQuery.
I can include it with
a single line that
says source equals blah to
the jQuery, and then off I go.
What we're talking
about is the fact
that you have to first of all
get all these command line
tools.
And you have to go crazy
over this whole pipeline
before you even are able
to get to Hello World.
We can't forget that
Hello World experience,
because that's how
people get started.
If not, we run the risk
of being-- essentially
making an SDK for the web.
JAKE: I think you've forgotten
about the main problem
with this.
And it's now like
if we want people
to be developing for the web,
one thing they have to learn
is Git.
PAUL: I don't think that
Git is a big deal, actually.
You don't have to.
JAKE: Are you sure
you're not just
forgetting how difficult
the learning curve was.
PAUL: My Git workflow is
typically to type tower,
hit Enter, and then use a GUI.
JAKE: I still think
you need to understand
how version control works.
Not just normal version control,
but Git version control,
where it's all--
you can re-base.
But even if you amend
the last commit,
it's actually creating
a new commits,
because are mutable things.
People need to understand that,
just to start with the web.
PAUL: [WHINE] They
don't have to.
Again, you could
download jQuery.
Just download, right?
JAKE: And this is what we need.
PAUL: Go on.
JAKE: No.
Exactly what you say.
Is when someone has a Git repo
with a library or something,
there must be a download link.
Even it's just linking into
the source, a single source,
or in a disk folder,
like a build version.
There should be a click
there that someone
could copy and paste
that JavaScript
and now they're good.
PAUL: Right,
because if you don't
want to go in for any
of this, and you just
want to use this library,
there is a better way here.
Where you can include in all
the workflow and do that.
And it is a good thing and
a professional thing to do.
If you just need it, go to the
disk folder, get the thing,
use it, smile a happy
smile, and that's your day.